each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available okay so yes I'm Nick Benton
I'm a researcher here working the
programming principles and tools group
I've been here since 1998 which is
nearly when the lab started not quite um
so yeah so it all starts with coffee so
uh so the popular perception is that uh
mathematicians and computer programmers
are both machines for turning coffee
into strangely incomprehensible streams
of symbols um and uh mathematicians
produces their output
theorems and computer programmers
produce as their output executable code
and a priori it seems as though these
are two quite different sorts of stuff
so in particular mathematics is about
eternal varities it's static the truths
of mathematics hold for all time whereas
computer programs they're much more
active they do things um and there seems
to be quite a quite a difference between
the uh between the philosophies of of of
mathematics and computer science and
what I'm going to talk about today is
about how really these two things are
the same they can both be reduced to
logic and that that interaction between
logic and computation is at the heart of
some of the most uh exciting philosophy
uh and uh and recent developments in
Computer Science and
Mathematics so really it all goes back
to the Greeks um the Greeks were the
first people to um formalize the notion
of a proof as a sort of uh uncontestable
argument to your conclusion from a bunch
of obviously true um
axioms so the the simplest form of proof
is the syllogism um the syllogisms were
first described by I guess well first
written down by Aristotle in about 350
BC and uh here we have a example of
syllogistic reasoning so it says all
babies are illogical nobody is despised
who can manage a crocodile and illogical
person are despised and from these three
statements you can deduce if you stop
and think about it for a second or two
that no baby can manage a crocodile um
so the reason for this slightly fanciful
uh example which is due to leis Carol um
is that the important thing about
syllogistic reasoning that Aristotle
spotted is that the shape of a valid
argument doesn't depend on what the
statements are actually about There are
rules for deducing True Facts from
assumed facts which are in variant under
what the actual facts
are so uh this gentleman here is
supposed to be but probably doesn't look
anything like uid um so he wrote a very
famous book in 300 BC called The
Elements which contains um what he knew
of geometry and arithmetic and many
other things and in particular uh he
introduced uh generations of school
children to the idea of doing formal
proof in the area of geometry so he
started started with a bunch of axioms
statements about geometry that he took
as um as as as basic and then from there
you could deduce all sorts of Highly
non-obvious facts about geometric
figures so here's an example of the
sorts of thing that was in UK's element
and was was was taught to all school
children for 2,000 years but probably no
longer uh this is the's theorem the
theorem says that if you have a a
triangle all of whose vertices are on U
the circumference of a circle and the
hypotenuse of which is um a diameter of
the circle then this angle up here is
always a right angle and this is far
from obvious and the way that uid
explained that you could convince
yourself that this absolutely had to be
true um is by constructing this new line
here from o to B and observing that this
triangle OAB is isoceles because this is
a radius of the circle and this is the
radius of the circle hence this angle
here Alpha and this angle here also
Alpha must be the same
likewise this triangle OBC is also Isles
because that's a radius and that's a
radius so this angle here and this angle
here must be the same beta now he's
already proved in an earlier proposition
that the sum of the angles inside a
triangle is 180 so if we now look what
what we've got as the angles of the
triangle we have 2 Alpha plus 2 Beta is
180 therefore this angle here Alpha plus
beta must be 90 brilliant um so many
people um have been enraptured really by
the the mixture of Ingenuity and
inevitability in arguments like this um
and there's a rather there's a rather
lovely sonnet from the 1920s written by
somebody slightly overheated and young I
think called uid alone has looked on
beauty bear and there's also a a rather
lovely account of Thomas Hobbs falling
in love with geometry on discovering the
elements in a gentleman's
Library um so one of the things actually
I'll just point out right now about
these axioms that's quite interesting is
that actually if you read these there a
strange mixture of
declarative statements about things that
are true and procedural statements about
things you can do statements so so so
this this statement says that um it's a
declarative statement I mean I didn't
read the whole thing but it says if you
have a straight line falling on two
straight lines and the interior angles
are like this then something is true
whereas these are operations which
you're allowed to
perform so moving forward to the uh 17th
century this is one of my absolute
Heroes this is godri Li nits um so he's
probably best known around here for the
priority dispute over the discovery of
the calculus with um with Newton but uh
he did many other things he was a true
polymath he did philosophy mathematics
logic but he also did politics and law
and all sorts of things he's responsible
for binary numbers um he's responsible
for uh the mysterious word monad which
those of you who have come across hll
will uh will know uh he's responsible
for the very notion of a function a
mathematical function as being a a
relationship between inputs and outputs
so one of his particular inut interests
was mechanical Computing so this gadget
down here is one of the earliest
calculators it's called the stepped
reckoner um and this could do the four
basic arithmetic operations of addition
subtraction multiplication and division
and uh his construction of this was
enough to get him elected to the role
Society but he he had much grander ideas
about what you could do with machine
means to um to formalize reasoning
processes so here's a a statement he had
this Vision that the only way to rectify
our reasonings is to make them as
tangible as those of the mathematicians
so that we can find our error at a
glance and when there are disputes among
persons we can simply say calcul us that
is let us calculate without further Ado
to see who is right so he had this clear
idea that you could um you could turn
reasoning into something like
calculation and he knew that calculation
was something that you could do on a
machine in fact he had completely
crazily ambitious ideas he thought he
could come up with a what he called the
characteristica universalis which was a
a universal language in which all human
thoughts could be expressed made up out
of Words which corresponded to every
indivisible notion and that then there
would be uh a calculus rosata
rosinator uh which was a system for
deducing new true facts from uh in this
language from from ones that you already
had by by a purely mechanical
process so one of the things that that
livit clearly understood was the
relationship between logical reasoning
and computation on
numbers and uh this was something that
was taken up in the uh 19th century by
George bull so his uh um investigations
into the laws of thought from 1854 um is
the first place that it was really
worked out how you could um compute with
the numbers 0 and one behaving like The
Logical Notions of false and true so
this is an extract from his uh from his
1854 book um and this is the proof of
what Aristotle called the principle of
contradiction um we would call the law
of the excluded middle that something
cannot be simultaneously true and false
um and it's it's worth kind of seeing
how this works it's completely gorgeous
so he starts out with this which he
calls a law of thought um and uh the uh
the way this works is zero is like false
and and one is like true and
multiplication is like conjunction in
logic um and disjunction is like
addition modulo 2 and negation is like
subtraction from one so he starts this
law of thought x^2 equal x which in its
logical re reasoning means x and x is
the same as X right so knowing something
twice is the same thing as knowing it
once so so this he thinks of as obvious
as a as a as as a law of of thought of
logic but he then manipulates this in an
arithmetical way so he subtracts x^2
from both sides to get x - x^2 = 0 and
then factorizes this taking the X's out
x * 1 - x is equal to Z so now Under The
Logical interpretation this says X and
not X is false okay so something can't
be true and false at the same
time so everything which had been done
uh up to this point uh was propositional
logic so there was there were a
collection of statements and they were
true and false and you could combine
them with and and or and implies and so
forth um and the really big uh step
forward came with frager uh in his uh B
Griff shrift from 1879 he first
introduced formally the notion of
logical quantifiers so you could now
make logical statements that were about
sets of individuals so this upside down
a for those who've not met it before I
imagine most people probably have means
for all and this backwards e means there
exists so you could now say for all
things like this there exists something
like that and so forth he was also very
keen on notation um so he was the first
person to introduce um a nice notation
for writing down proofs as as objects so
this is his version of the law of modus
ponin uh so he introduced this notion of
having a notation of having a horizontal
line where you have assumptions on the
top of the horizontal line and
conclusions on the bottom of the
horizontal line and he introduced this
Turn Style symbol as we call it this
chap which means something is is
provable and he had a rather nice notion
for implications so what this means in
his notation is if B implies a and you
know B then you can deduce a um and
actually this notation for implication
which we would write B Arrow a is rather
lovely because I it looks not
accidentally like a transistor so the
IDE is B is switching a
um so uh so he introduced he introduced
quantifies he came up with a nice
formalization of first order logic he
wanted to go a bit further um and in his
uh grun cassettes of 1893 and 1903 he
attempted to use logic to um formalize
all of
arithmetic so uh so he was a belie
believer in logicism the belief that
mathematics could be reduced to logic um
so uh so he worked out this logical
system which was powerful enough to
prove things about the natural
numbers and um uh it was a wonderful
achievement but uh just as he was going
to press um he received an unfortunate
letter and as he had to kind of insert
into into the book at the last minute uh
a little statement along these lines
it's hardly anything more unfortunate
can befall a scientific writer than to
have one of the foundations of his
edifice shaken after the work is
finished this was the position I was
placed in by a letter of Mr Bertrand
Russell just when the printing of this
volume was nearing its completion so it
turns out that formalizing mathematics
in terms of logic is actually quite
tricky to get
right so this is Bertrand Russell um on
the left here um who Not only was a
great logician but looked like a great
logician um and uh the Paradox that he
discovered in frager's logical
system uh is
uh well frager's logical system allowed
um unrestricted comprehension if you had
a property of things you could make the
set of all things that satisfied that
property and Russell said aha what about
this which this is the notation for this
in English consider the set of all sets
which are not members of
themselves so the set of all X such that
X is not a member of X in modern
notation
well you then ask yourself is this set a
member of itself well if it is a member
of itself then the characteristic
formula associated with that is says
it's not a member of itself and if it's
not a member of itself then it should be
in this set so the idea that whenever
you had a property of things you could
form the collection of all things with
that property was inherently paradoxical
um and this was the this was a a blow to
to fraus system but Russell didn't just
um point out the inconsistency in in
frager system he also suggested a
solution and his solution was to
introduce types so the idea was that
rather than just having a universe of
stuff sets all of which um could be in
this membership relation with with with
one another or not
that wellform statements ought to obey
some kind of typing discipline so very
much like the types that we that we know
programming languages now this is where
this is where the idea was first first
introduced so under Russell's system uh
state state um expressions like this
would not be would not be well formed so
you couldn't you couldn't talk about
whether a set was a member of itself
sets could be members of other sets but
they the types kept them apart in such a
way that this was not even a well formed
notion so together with a collaborator
Alfred North Whitehead um Russell came
took his theory of types and attempted
to construct
um uh uh as much of mathematics as he
could in this very very aere logical
language and uh they wrote three volumes
um about 100 years ago 1910 and 1913 so
we're in the anniversary of the of the
last um last volume coming out and uh
they got they got quite a way um in
formalizing mathematics but it's um it
was uh incredibly painful work Russell
said that uh his his brain never quite
recovered from the strain of writing
prinkipia Mathematica and indeed I think
he he probably did um not all that much
logic after that um but yes you got as
far as sets and Cardinals and ordinals
and the reals and so forth there was
another fix to frager system uh which is
actually the one which is uh uh at least
unofficially used by most practicing
mathematicians these days so that was to
take the a set theory due to Zemo uh
including an axiim of called Foundation
which
uh which like types uh uh stratifies
things so that sets are all built up in
a cumulative hierarchy of universes and
statements like this would be uh uh
would be ill formed and that that
Foundation Axiom is due to John Von nman
who um also worked on uh early computers
as well as as well as logic and we'll
see that throughout that the people who
made contributions to early computers
and the people who made contributions to
to logic were were usually the
same so here's a famous extract from
prinkipia Mathematica to give you some
idea of uh uh of what working in this
system was like I have a copy upstairs
and there's hundreds and hundreds of
pages of this stuff um so this is this
is this is famous because this is Page
379 of the first volume um and uh and we
see this kind of strange mixture of
formal symbol manipulation and then at
the bottom the classic line that says
from this proposition it will follow
when arithmetical addition has been
defined that 1 + 1 equals 2 and the the
proof of that fact is completed on page
86 of volume two um so you can see that
that proving substantial statements in a
system like Russell's is sort of
possible but incredibly painful there's
pages and pages of this of this this
kind of um very fine syntactical
manipulation
required so the next uh the next
character in the story is uh David
Hilbert he's one of the uh one of the
great figures of uh I suppose late 19th
and early 20th century mathematics uh he
was a professor at the University of
Gan and he's famous for many things
um at
uh
1899 he um he redid uid in a in a formal
way so rather than the kind of informal
reasoning that the Greeks had done he
had a formal language like that used by
russin Whitehead and he axiomatized
geometric Concepts in symbols he had 21
axioms I think for geometry and he redid
quite a lot of what was in ukl In This
Very formal symbol manipulating
way um he's famous for giving a speech
at the international Congress of
mathematicians in 1900 in which he laid
out a grand program of challenges for
mathematics for the coming Century uh
which in fact had a huge uh uh influence
on on mathematics throughout the 20th
century and indeed some of the some of
the problems are still of Interest today
um but around about this time um about
1920 there was a there was a feeling
that there was a a kind of crisis in the
foundations of mathematics so people had
started to get more formal about things
uh and about what counted as a proof and
in
particular they found themselves
troubled by not knowing what what
counted as a valid proof when you
started talking about
Infinity um so lots and lots of proofs
involved different Notions of infinity
and it wasn't at all clear clear what um
uh what counted as a valid proof and
everyone was feeling a bit shaky and
uncertain because of the discovery of
paradoxes when people tried to tried to
tie these things down uh but he was a
great believer that we
could write a universally accepted
collection of formal rules which would
capture all of mathematics uh and which
would give us certainty back and so he
he he had a sort of Call to Arms in 1920
he said the definitive clarification of
the nature of the it has become
necessary not merely for the special
interests of the individual Sciences but
for the honor of human understanding
itself so he set in he set in motion
what what's usually known as Hilbert's
program he wanted to reconstitute
mathematics from the ground up including
treatments of Infinities in a completely
formal logical system which we could
prove using finite proofs was consistent
in other words it should be impossible
to derive a contradiction like 1 equal 2
or true equals
false it should be complete in that all
true statements should be provable in
this formal system and furthermore it
should be decidable there should be a
finite terminating procedure for
deciding whether or not any statement
written down in this formal language was
provable or not and which because of
completeness means true or not okay this
is called the in shiding problem and
Hilbert really believed that this could
be done um so he said here is the
problem seek its solution you can find
it by pure reason for in mathematics
there is no ignorabimus there is no such
thing as we don't know as I don't know
and he a famous
line we must know we shall know which is
actually on his on his gravestone I
think um
unfortunately clever young Austrian
called Kurt girdle came along and showed
that Hilbert's program as he had laid it
out was actually unachievable so he's
wrote a now very famous paper in 1931
called on formly undecidable
propositions of prinkipia Mathematica
and related systems so what girle did
was he observed that the formal systems
that you used to uh uh to prove things
were themselves subject to reasoning
indeed you could
encode sequences of uh um expression in
in your formal language as natural
numbers and you could encode the
inference rules of your formal system in
terms of facts about natural numbers so
that statements about the system become
statements about
arithmetic so if the system is powerful
enough to prove interesting things about
arithmetic then it can always talk
indirectly through this interpretation
about
itself so he then observed that if if
you have such a system you can construct
a proposition P which when you read so a
proposition p on the face of it is just
a statement about uh about arithmetic
about natural numbers but under this
interpretation of these natural numbers
being talking about derivations in your
formal system the reading of what p
means is p is not provable so P says I
am not
provable
now this has to be true because if P
were false then P would be provable and
if p is provable um and says p is not
provable then you would have an
inconsistency in your system so if your
system is consistent it must be that P
is true I.E that P is not provable so
you now have a true statement which is
not provable so this I mean and this is
a completely generic argument I mean he
constructed it for for for for explained
how it worked for a particular system
but this applies to any formal system
that's consistent and strong enough to
talk about about arithmetic you can
always construct by one of these clever
encodings girdle numbering as it's known
um a statement which is true but not
provable so completeness is completely
unattainable um Hilbert was said to be
rather annoyed uh when he when he heard
about this
result so the next person to come along
was churing
who dealt the next blow to Hilbert's
program so if you recall he wanted
something which was consistent complete
complete and we've seen that
completeness is not attainable but he
also wanted something which was
decidable that there should be a a finit
procedure for telling whether any
statement is provable or not so if we
give up completeness it's still possible
that we have a system that is powerful
enough to prove not all true statements
but enough true statements and then we
would have this mechanical procedure
again you see this connection between
computation this active thing uh and and
and deduction this static um uh static
mathematical view of things that you
could you could still have a decision
procedure something which we would now
think of as as an algorithm uh for
deciding whether things were provable or
not but what uring did by an argument
very much like that used by girdle is
show that in actual fact the shiding
problem this decidability was also
unattainable um so uh so what he did was
he introduced the the touring machine
and showed um as I guess Byron probably
told you about an hour or two ago um the
undecided of the halting problem so the
touring machine was a an idealized model
of well a human a human being doing
doing computation and he showed that uh
the question of whether a touring
machine haltered was not decidable by an
algorithm and so his his argument was a
diagonal one um involving uh something
applied to itself much as this uh much
as this statement P talks about this
statement P um here you have a machine
which is f which has fed its own code um
uh to make this to make this proof go
through so so he showed that uh so so
this was the the undecidability of the
halting problem showed that the en
shining problem was also undecidable
because um you uh if the machine halts
then there will be a if you like some
kind of finit demonstration that it's
halts and so you don't this shows that
it's not decidable whether or not there
is is such a
derivation so uh so Turing also worked
on on codebreaking very famously it's um
100 years last year since his birth so
there were lots of celebrations about
about that um and he worked on he worked
on codebreaking and he he also worked on
uh a couple of of of real uh famous
computers the ace and the Manchester
mark one but one thing that's not so
wonder I didn't know until a few years
ago was that in actual fact he also
worked on forly proving the correctness
of computer programs so there's a a
paper which hardly ever gets cited back
from 19 49 called checking a large
routine uh which has this uh probably to
you slightly unreadable figure but uh
but basically what's uh what's here is
he's got a flowchart for a program and
he explains how you can convince
yourself that this program is is correct
by writing down uh logical statements
about the values of all the variables
that always hold when the program is at
particular points in the flowchart and
that's an idea that um we'll come back
to uh in a slide or
two
so churing did his uh PhD at uh
Princeton under this chap Alonzo
church and
uh Church introduced a foundational
model of computing which was slightly
different um from that of Turing um he
was actually looking for a foundation of
logic which was more natural than the
type theory of Russell or the set theory
of of Zelo and he took as his primitive
notion not sets but functions and he
introduced this which is called the
Lambda
calculus so uh the Lambda calculus is a
is a very simple language so the grammar
of terms is given here it says terms m&n
are either variables X or the
application of one term to another term
or the abstraction of a variable in a
term so this is a this a variable that
stands for something this is thought of
as a function applied to an argument and
if m is an expression with a with a
variable X in it somewhere this is the
function which takes an input X and
produces whatever m is as the argument
and this collection of terms is um has a
well there are a number of things number
of rules you can apply but the most
important one is this which is called
beta reduction so this says Lambda x. M
this is the function which takes an X
and gives you back M when you apply that
function to an argument it reduces to
the body of the function with the
argument substituted for the variable so
this logical calculus um turned out to
be inconsistent as a logic uh uh Steven
cleeny and uh Berkeley rter uh proved
that his logic was actually inconsistent
it was subject to a paradox which was
quite like the other paradoxes that um
that people have come up with um but the
calculus itself is not inconsistent not
all terms regist to each other under
this um under this um
relation and um this calculus is the
foundation for modern functional
programming languages like hasal ml F
and so forth and there's a there's a
rather lovely quote from church who was
completely didn't have the idea of this
thing being uh being a useful way of
programming computers or anything that
there may indeed be uses for the system
other than as a logic which has been
shown very much right in the last few
years so this this version of the Lambda
calculus is untyped it doesn't have
Types on it there is just one class of
terms but Church also Al came up with
typed variance of the Lambda
calculus back in 1940 so remember I mean
this is all prior to anybody building
any computers
um and uh and here's a a presentation of
uh of Church's um simple type Lambda
calculus in modern programming language
loation so um this is very much the
heart of programming language research
if you go to a programming language
conference like icfp or Popple then
pretty much every paper has a figure
that looked a bit like this in it
somewhere most things that people do
involve adding various sorts of fancy
bells and whistles to this system that
church came up with in in in 1940 and
here's a a typical functional programmer
getting excited about the type Lambda
calculus so um so as I say this uses
frager's the presentation of the system
uses frager's uh notation for um for
derivations and the form is that you
have a collection an environment a
context which tells you what type um uh
the the variables have and under such a
context you can deduce that some
expression has some type so if in your
collection of assumptions you have that
the variable X has Type A you can deduce
that the variable X has Type A not
terribly
exciting but more exciting here is that
this the the way this is read is if
under some assumptions M has Type A Arro
B so this is m is a function which takes
A's as inputs and produces B's as
outputs and under the same set of
assumptions n is something of type A the
input type then what you get by applying
the function m to the argument n is
something of type
B similarly if under some number of
assumptions plus the extra assumption
that X has Type A you can deduce that M
has Type B then just under the
assumptions gamma you can deduce that
the function Lambda X do M function that
takes X as input and gives you back m is
a function from A's to B's and there are
also constructions of pair Pairs and
disjoint unions so if you have an A and
A B you can pair them together to get
something of type A cross B and if you
have something of type A cross B then
you can project out the first component
of it and get back something of type A
and uh and similar rules for uh for
disjoint unions which include the
booleans so um so church had intended
his Lambda calculus to be the basis for
a logic but um in fact there's a deeper
con C between his typed Lambda calculus
and logic than he realized so to see
that we have to go to a different
presentation of logic which is due to
this chap Gart gensen in 1935 he uh
introduced a presentation of logic
called natural deduction so he didn't
like the way that frager and Hilbert had
set up their formal systems the way that
they mixed up all the connectives in
their descriptions of what the what the
rules of the system were and he uh he
introduced this this um this way of
presenting logic uh in which each
logical connective came with rules which
explained how you introduced it how uh
how how you deduced something that
contained that logical connective and
how you eliminated it how if you got one
of those things you could get rid of it
so here's his presentation of of logic
so the way he writes it is that there's
a bunch of assumptions up on the top and
a proof is a sequence of steps that
allow you to deduce some
conclusion so here's moda's ponin again
this was the one we saw in in in uh in
in in frager's um uh work so here this
says if you've deduced a implies B and
you've deduced a You can conclude B and
here this notation here is corresponds
to the idea that if you deduced B from
an assumption a the assumptions are all
kind of floating at the top then you can
conclude a implies B and strike out that
assumption right so similarly here if
you have proved a and and you've proved
B then you can conclude A and B and so
on so this system is very pretty has
lots of nice symmetries the other thing
that Genson introduced was the notion
that proofs themselves had a had a
Dynamics they had um uh they they were
subject to equations so the idea was
that if you had two proofs of the of the
same fact but one of them was like the
other one but just had some silly
detours in it then you could remove the
detours and it was kind of the same
proof so here's an example of of that so
here I've got a proof of a implies B um
and I've got a proof of a and a
deduction of B using modus ponent so
here I introduced implication and here I
immediately eliminated it well the proof
of a implies B had an assumption of a
before before so I can take this proof
that gives me an A and now this proof
was assuming an A and I can plug that
proof on top and I get the simpler proof
that just has B at the bottom and the a
has is is somewhere in the the middle so
the assumptions here or whatever the
assumptions were um up here so he had
this notion of proof
simplification now if you take Genson
system and you change the notation a
little bit so you turn it sideways so
this is using the uh um uh keeping the
assumptions that Genson kept dangling
freely at the top you're writing them
all down using gamma the same letter as
I used before then this is what gon's
rules look like so here we have that you
have proved a implies B you've proved a
You can conclude B and here you've
proved B on an assumption of a and
you've deduced a implies B without the
Assumption of a and so on so you just
take gon rules and turn them sideways
and keep track of the uh of the
assumptions at every
step and then you change your notation a
little bit so the symbols we write for
implication and conjunction and so forth
are completely arbitrary so instead of
writing the implication symbol I write
this arrow and instead of writing a
logical conjunction I'll write this
cross I end up with something that's
starting to look very familiar so the
final step is to say well we're taking
these proofs seriously
so what we would like is not just to
have a derivation that something is true
but to pair together the fact that it's
true with a record of what the
derivation was so all we have to do to
do that is for each one of these logical
inference rules we have to have
something that records what logical rule
we used at each step so that now the big
tree of derivations with all the that
that has kind of axioms at the top and
the conclusion at the bottom will be
encoded in some expression so all we
need to do is come up with a new
expression for each one of these rules
and then by combining those up we'll
we'll keep a record of what the proof
was so again exactly what syntax we
choose for that doesn't matter but it
turns out there's a syntax which works
rather nicely which is precise the
syntax of Church's Lambda calculus so um
so here we had a proof of a implies b
and a proof of a and we just have to we
say well we'll let M be at some notation
for that proof and N be some notation
for that proof and then we just say well
this proof was obtained by applying this
rule to these two sub proofs M and N so
we need some something which has an m in
it and an n in it and we'll choose to
write M applied to n for that for that
proof and similarly here for Lambda
abstraction and so forth so if you take
Church's type Lambda calculus and gon's
natural deduction um are exactly the
same system and in fact gon's notion of
proof simplification those eliminations
of detours in proofs that he introduced
correspond exactly to the beta reduction
rules of the Lambda calculus which we
would think of as describing how a
functional program executes how how
functions are applied to to their
arguments so we get this correspondence
between proofs in constructive logic and
Notions that we're familiar with from
programming languages it's called the
curry how isomorphism after Haso Curry
who was the first person to notice this
and after whom obviously the hasool
programming language is uh is named um
and uh and the correspondence goes like
this so propositions in the logic behave
like type behave like types um for terms
proofs in the logic correspond to
program so a program
um a program has a type is the same
thing as saying that a proof proves a
proposition The Logical operation of
conjunction behaves exactly like the
programming language notion of pairing
The Logical notion of disjunction
corresponds to disjoint Union types in
programming languages which C
programmers would think of as a kind of
special use of um of Union types imp
most importantly implication in the
logic corresponds to forming a function
space in the programming language and
the process of proof normalization
behaves very much like the operational
semantics the step-by-step reduction
rules of the programming
language so this propositions as types
analogy is one of the greatest ideas in
programming language Theory it's proved
incredibly fruitful and it extends to
lots and lots of systems that are more
complicated than the simple type system
that um that I just showed you and if
you look through the history of the
subject you discover amazingly
frequently you get exactly the same idea
invented twice once by a logician and
once by a computer scientist and a
particularly uh a good example of that
is the uh the second order Lambda
calculus so these two chaps are Jean
Girard who's a French logician very
famous as the inventor of linear logic
um and John Reynolds who's a computer
scientist uh from Ki melon University
who sadly died recently and they
simultaneously invented the same system
so Girard was interested in the theory
of proofs and complexity analysis and he
invented what's called system F or
impredicative second order propositional
intuitionistic
logic and Reynolds was interested in
programming languages and uh being able
to write programs that were typed but
had more generic types what we would Now
call polymorphic types uh than before
and he invented the polymorphic Lambda
calculus so Gerard invented system F in
71 and um independently Reynolds
invented the poly Lambda calculus in 74
and they're exactly the same system and
those are the foundations for uh
parametric polymorphism in hll or
generics in C and so on in fact all
modern programming languages um really
have have polymorphic functions these
days this calculus is very expressive
you can encode inductive data types of
the sort that most programming languages
give you as a new notion just using
polymorphic functions um and the
correspondence between logical Notions
and um computational Notions has been
really kind of well studied in this
context and one of the one of the nicest
things that came out of that is that the
discovery by John Mitchell and Gordon
plin that second order second order
existential quantification which is
actually encodable in the in in system f
um in the logic corresponds exactly to
the notion of abstract data type in uh
in programming
languages so this use of of of of
fancier type language
starts to lead you and and the
propositions as types analogy starts to
lead you to think of types as like
specifications for programs so a program
having a type is like a program uh
meeting a
specification and um other people not
working on Lambda calculus based
languages had also done great work on
Logics for proving that programs meet
their specifications so I guess most
people have seen this logic which is due
to Tony hore who works in our group now
um so this is a logic for proving
properties of simple imperative programs
and the the shape of it is that you uh
you prove that a program has uh a uh
satisfies what's called a wh triple so
this says if you start the program in a
state satisfying a where a is some
predicate some assertion about the state
um uh then the program will if it
terminates land up in a state that
satisfies What's called the post
condition so this says the skip program
does nothing so this says for any a um
if the if the state beforehand satisfies
a and you execute skip which does
nothing then the state afterwards will
satisfy a which is kind of obvious And
Then There are rules for each one of the
constructs of the simple imperative
programming language so um if uh if C1
takes State statisfying a to State
statisfying a prime and C2 takes any
state satisfying a primed to something
satisfying a double primed then if you
start the sequential composition C1 then
C2 um in a state satisfying a you will
end up in a state satisfying able primed
so so we have Logics for reasoning about
programs like this and we have we have
we have type systems for uh for
functional programs which can be read as
as specifications in a very similar way
now about the time when Tony came up
with this 1969 or so the status in both
mathematics and um or shortly afterwards
in mathematics and computer science was
kind of similar we
had we had nice stories nice formal
stories about what the of practicing
mathematicians really meant and there
was a so the story was well whatever you
do can be translated into one of these
formal
systems um so in theory when you write
something in your mathematics Journal
paper um it's shorthand for a statement
in one of these formal languages
probably um Z Frankle set theory with
the a of choice um but nobody actually
would ever do that it was clearly
completely impractical to ever prove
anything you cared about in one of these
formal systems and people would point to
ridiculous things like Pria ma ma
Mathematica as examples of how how
ludicrous that was and there were many
papers published um in fact still some
people do publish papers which say how
crazy the idea of formalizing
mathematics in a formal system is as a
way of actually getting any maths done
and exactly the same situation pertains
in the world of uh software verification
so we had systems like this we had types
we we had types which weren't terribly
expressive then we had program Logics
like this which could prove interesting
properties of programs but it was clear
impractical to ever prove any property
of any program you ever cared
about so the sort of formal logistic
dream was uh was very much idealized
compared to the real world in terms of
the work of practicing mathematicians or
practicing software
Engineers but these things these things
can change quite rapidly and of course
the thing that makes them change in both
cases is the fact that these formal
systems are very much amable to being
manipulated on a
computer so these two chaps are ti Kon
and jarard HT and they came up in the
late 8s so mid mid late ' 80s with the
calculus of inductive constructions so
this is a Lambda calculus very much like
the type Lambda calculus that I showed
you earlier uh but it's a bit more
powerful so it has a single syntactic
structure in which types and terms live
and its types uh feature something
called dependency that it's a
dependently type language what that
means is that the types can mention
terms so what that gives you is
something which is very much like
Church's type Lambda calculus except it
has a lot more power even though as a
formal set of rules it's not terribly
much more complicated so now the types
can express fairly arbitrary
specifications of your programs so you
can write down a type which is the type
of functions which compute the factorial
or um or functions which um uh compute
the length of lists or whatever so those
sorts of things can now be expressed in
the the type language the sorts of
things that are in the logic due to Tony
for for reasoning about um imperative
programs but now we're talking about
much fancier High typed objects we're
talking about functions functions on
functions rather than just flat store
the way that Tony was so this remarkable
remarkably simple set of rules gives you
a very powerful uh logic and it can also
courtesy of the propositions of types
analogy be seen as a programming
language with a very ful type system and
this has been implemented in a system
called Co which is a computer
implementation of the calculus of
inducted constructions which can be seen
simultaneously as a very a very fancily
typed pure functional programming
language or a computer program in which
you can interactively do almost
arbitrary mathematics and because of the
way that the logic works and the way
that the system is implemented you can
build up remarkably complicated bits of
code or remarkably complicated
mathematical theorems using the power of
abstraction which kind of gives you a
multiplying Factor each time you apply
it such that it is actually feasible to
prove non-trivial mathematical results
and have everything at the end of the
day expand out to a statement in this
very simple formal
language so these systems have
become usable over just the last five or
six years and there's been a explosion
of work in using them to produce
completely formally verified proofs of
very non-trivial bits of mathematics and
to prove non-trivial pieces of software
so looking at mathematics first the guy
on the left here is George Gontier
another person who works in our group um
and in 2005 he used Co to produce a
completely formally verified proof of
the forc color theorem a theorem I guess
everyone's heard of that you can color
any planer map uh using most four colors
where the rule is that adjacent regions
mustn't mustn't be colored with the same
color and this is you know this is a
problem which goes back um uh uh many
many years it was proved in 1976 by
Appel and Harkin they did a paper proof
which used the
computer uh to check a whole bunch of
special cases that arose in the proof it
was custom computer code um and you had
to kind of read the paper proof to
understand even what the computer code
was supposed to do um and this sparked
this this this proof of a of a
long-standing open problem sparked a lot
of debate about the role of computers uh
in proof and the proof that George came
up with in 2005 is is is of a quite
different character he didn't just write
a computer program to help him with his
calculations he used a computer to
verify the actual proof right down to
the Last Detail so there's a statement
of the theorem is completely
comprehensible and if you believe that
the logic that's implemented in Co is
consistent then you pretty much have to
believe
um that the proof is correct so the
computers checked every Last Detail so
the computer doesn't do the proof for
you you have to interactively construct
the proof with the help of the computer
but the computer will check that you
haven't forgotten everything and that
every step you applied was
valid uh this chaps Tom hailes so he he
had a proof in uh whenever it was
um I forget to so a few years ago Tom
Tom haes proved a very long-standing uh
open problem so this is the Kepler
conjecture which as you can guess from
the name is quite old 1611 I think um
and this was that uh if you're trying to
stack spheres then the densest way that
you can possibly P pack spheres is um
hexagonal close packing or cubic close
packing this kind of pyramid shape and
this is sort of intuitively uh obvious
and well known to anyone who's ever kind
of put cannibals on the on their ship or
or grapefruit on their grocery store um
but proving that that was their densest
possible arrangement of spheres it's
incredibly difficult and uh and Tom
Hales had a similar experience to appell
and Haren he he he did a proof of this
which was a complete breakthrough but he
used a computer program to um uh to
check a whole bunch of special cases and
uh and the journal he submitted it to
said well we're not quite sure about
this and sent it off to a bunch of
referees who took I think four years to
study the proof and they finally came
back and said well we're 99% certain
it's right but we're not quite sure
about this this computer stuff um so Tom
said right in that case I'm going to
really prove it on a computer and check
every last detail and so he's had a long
running project going called fbck um
which is formal proof of Kepler um to to
produce a complete formal verification
of the proof of uh of the kep conjecture
and that's kind of ongoing but uh but
but looks like it's going to work and
then just last year after having proved
the Four Color theorem in 2005 George
announced the formal proof of a a
substantially more impressive piece of
mathematics the fight Thompson theorem
so um this is a this is a a graph of the
dependency uh uh between the different
modules of the proof that Geor did
of the the fight Thompson theorem this
is a proof in in finite group Theory um
also known as the odd order theorem says
that every um uh every group finite
group of of odd order is uh is
soluble so uh uh this also says that
every uh OD order simple group must be
uh must be the integers modulo for some
for some p and this is this when this
was published on paper was a a kind of
shocking proof it was a it was a proof
that was 255 pages long it's now
published in in two books and and George
has formalized every last detail of that
proof which is a truly outstanding uh
achievement and the one of the things
the secret source that George uses when
he does these proofs um uh one of one of
one of them is that he uses the fact
that this system is both a system for
computation and a system for DED
deduction so so you can write deductive
proofs in Co where you just say well
this is true because this and this and
then for because of that this is true
but can also do computation and
that if you use that intelligently that
can greatly reduce the size of the proof
and the amount of manual interaction
that you you have to do so you could
prove you know that 2 plus 2 equals 4 by
applying pianos axioms for to for for
arithmetic and you would have a proof
that 2 plus 2 = 4 which would be a
derivation in the logic but cck can
compute so if you ask to prove that
2 plus 2 equal 4 it says well they're
the same thing so that because it knows
that two 2 plus 2 reduces it has
computation built in as well as
deduction and intelligent use of that is
the uh is the thing that makes uh makes
these proofs of substantial bits of
mathematics
possible so there's also been an
explosion in the use of formal systems
like in programming language
research just over the last five or six
years so there a couple of big landmark
things that everyone refers to so one of
them is a verification of um an
operating system system kernel called
sl4 um by a group at Niar in Australia
so they have a they have a proof that a
a bunch of C code meets its meets a
specification and there's a formally
verified compiler for a seal like
language that was done by zavier ly at
inria using the system and just in
our group this has been taken up just in
the last five or six years so we have I
don't know 35 40 Projects now um that
have used to formalize some or all
of the work that they were doing and in
all sorts of all sorts of areas so
compilers um domain Theory which is kind
of the mathematics behind modeling
programming languages the dimension
types that are in F have been formalized
in uh proofs of the uh
computational uh the the security of of
crypto Primitives uh right down to the
the computational definitions of
security uh been carried out in
here formalization of advanced module
systems the meaning of refinement type
systems languages like fstar a whole
bunch of programming log Logics for
reasoning about uh programs with
pointers separation Logics have been
formalized in Co here and the
foundations of termination analysis the
stuff that Byron was talking about
before been formalized in and I'll
just show you one of the uh one of the
projects I've been involved with
recently so so this this this I like
this because it kind of it's a good
example of what I was saying about this
being a being a system in which you
can do mathematics and you can do
programming and you can relate the two
so so here what we've done is we've
built a form model in Co of the x86
processor so we Define what the what the
processor architecture is we tell the
system it has these registers and so
forth um and these instructions and this
is how instructions are encoded in
memory um and then we express the
semantics of the process so how the
process of steps from one step to the
next um so this is the this is a a bunch
of stuff that you can't read that tells
you how a multiplication instruction uh
is executed in the processor and then on
top of that also inside the system we
can Define an assembly language and we
can explain how the Assembly Language
programs are mapped down to sequences of
bites and that function from Assembly
Language programs to sequences of bytes
is a function that we can actually
execute inside Co so we can write
Assembly Language programs in
compute them in Co to get a sequence of
bytes which we can extract from Co burn
onto a CD and boot a machine
from but then at the same time we can
use to Define a programming uh a
programming logic a system for reasoning
about properties of these Assembly
Language programs so the the logic is
defined in the system and the meaning of
assertions in the logic in terms of the
behavior of the Machine model that we
formalized in Co is all defined so the
soundness of the logic the fact that the
thing when you prove something about an
assembly language program it's a true
statement about how that will execute on
the processor is proved in Co and then
we can then in Co have Co check the
proofs of particular programs
that we have written in the embedded
Assembly Language so uh we get the
highest possible confidence that the
code that we write really satisfies the
specification when it's run on the
machine there's no external dependencies
other than so provided that our
model of x86 is correct we have the
highest Assurance we could possibly have
that the code um will behave itself and
you'll see we've got the architecture
the semantics the binary the this
compiler the language the specifications
the logic and the proof of a program and
they all live in one system and they can
all be related so we're mixing
computation and deduction in a in a in a
very uh a very tight way so I'll stop
there um the conclusion is we're making
significant progress in the last few
years towards realizing the dreams of
liit frager and Russell to have fully
formalized mathematics and of hore Scott
and others to have formally specified
and verified computer software and at
the same time we're getting powerful and
expressive programming
languages and I will leave you with last
week New Scientist which had an article
on mechanized proofing and their caption
is machine- minded mathematicians will
rule the future so stop
there